[Music]  kicking off et's Kardashian ketchup Kim  Kardashian back in the spotlight it's so  exciting the star made her first  official public appearance in months in  Dubai Friday for a makeup masterclass  back in LA Kylie Jenner debut de bold  blonde bob which has to be a wig she and  sister Khloe also goofed off on snapchat  I finally have Kylie Jenner lips khlo  money seemed to be in a silly mood on  Thursday the same day her new series  Revenge body premiered she shared a ton  of videos having fun with nieces at  north and Penelope glam room chronicles  Oh Syria who is eating cereal the 32  year old also looks fit end of fabulous  in these new flash dance inspired ads  for protein world and i love it and  kendall jenner had quite the celebrity  spotting herself  [Music]  you